in the book you have a picture this I
just have a lot of ridiculous questions
you have a picture of two Hospital
delivery robots with a caption that
reads by the way see your book I
appreciate that it keeps the humor in
you didn't run it by the PR department
no no one edited the book you got rushed
through
uh the thing the caption reads two
hospitals delivery robots whose sexy
nurse names Roxy and Lola made me roll
my eyes so hard they almost fell out
um what aspect of it made you roll your
eyes is it the naming it was the naming
the form factor is fine it's like a
little box on Wheels the fact that they
named them also great that'll let people
enjoy interacting with them we know that
even just giving a robot a name people
will uh it facilitates technology
adoption people will be like oh you know
Betsy made a mistake let's help her out
instead of the stupid robot doesn't work
but why lowly and Lola and Roxy like
those are too too sexy I mean there's
research showing that
a lot of robots are named according to
gender biases about the function that
they're fulfilling so
you know robots that are helpful and
assistance and are like nurses are
usually female gendered robots that are
you know powerful all wise computers
like Watson usually have like a booming
male uh coded voice and name so
like why like that's one of those things
right you're opening a can of worms for
no reason for no reason are you gonna
avoid this whole camera just give it a
different name like why Roxy
it's because people aren't even thinking
so to some extent I don't I don't like
PR departments but getting some feedback
on your work from a diverse set of
participants listening and taking in
things that help you identify your own
blind spots and then you can always make
your good leadership choices and good
like you can still ignore things that
you don't believe are an issue but
having the openness to take in feedback
and making sure that you're getting the
right feedback from the right people I
think that's really important so don't
unnecessarily propagate the biases of
society yeah why in the design
but uh if you're not careful though when
you when you do the research of
like
you might if you ran a poll with a lot
of people of all the possible names
these robots have they might come up
with Roxy and Lola as as as names they
um would enjoy most like that could come
up as uh
as the highest as in you do marketing
research and then
well that's what they did with Alexa
they did marketing research and nobody
wanted the male voice everyone wanted it
to be female what do you what do you
think about that like what
I mean if I if I were to say
I think the role of a great designer
again to go back to Johnny Ive is to
throw out the marketing research
like take it in do it learn from it but
like
if everyone wants Alexa to be a female
voice
the role of the designers to think
deeply about the future
of social agents in the home and think
like what does that future look like and
try to reverse engineer that future so
like in some sense there's this weird
tension like you want to listen to a lot
of people
but at the same time you want to you're
creating a thing that defines the future
of the world
and the people that you're listening to
are part of the past
so like that weird tension yeah I think
that's true and I think some companies
like apple have historically done very
well at understanding a market and
saying you know what our role is it's
not to listen to what the current market
says is to actually shape the market and
shape consumer preferences
companies have the power to do that they
can be Forward Thinking and they can
actually shift what the future of
technology looks like
and I agree with you that I would like
to see more of that especially when it
comes to
existing biases that we know
or or you know that that I think there's
the low-hanging fruit of companies that
don't even think about it at all and
aren't talking to the right people and
aren't getting the full information and
then there's companies that are just
like doing the safe thing and and giving
consumers what they want now but to be
really forward looking and be really
successful I think you have to make some
judgment calls about what the future is
going to be but do you think it's still
useful to gender and to name the robots
yes I mean
gender is the minefields but people I
it's really hard to get people to not
gender a robot in some way
so if you don't give it a name or you
give it a like ambiguous voice people
will just choose something and maybe
that's better than just like
uh you know entrenching something that
you've decided is best
but I do think it can be helpful on the
like anthropomorphism engagement level
to give it attributes that people
identify with yeah I think uh a lot of
roboticists I know they they don't
gender the robot they don't they even
try to avoid naming the robot or naming
it ain't something that is uh can be
used as a name in conversation kind of
thing and I think that actually
that's uh
irresponsible because
people are going to anthropomorphize the
thing anyway
so you're just uh removing from yourself
the responsibility of how they're
they're going to anthropomorphize it
that's a good point and so like you want
to be able to like they're going to do
it
you have to start to think about how
they're going to do it even if the robot
is like a Boston Dynamics robot that's
not supposed to have any kind of social
component
they're obviously going to project a
social component to it yeah like that
arm
I worked a lot a lot with quadruped now
with with the robot dogs you know that
arm people think is the head immediately
yeah it's supposed to be an arm but they
start to think it's a head and you have
to like acknowledge that you can't I
mean um they do now they do now well
they've deployed the robots and people
are like
oh my God the cops are using a robot dog
and so they have this PR Nightmare and
so they're like oh
yeah okay maybe we should hire some HRI
people
well Boston Dynamics is an interesting
company or any of the others that are
doing similar thing because
their their main source of money
is um in the industrial application so
like surveillance of factories and uh
doing dangerous jobs
so to them it's almost good PR to for
people to be scared of these things
because it's it's for some reason as you
talk about people are naturally for some
reason scared we could talk about that
of robots and so it becomes more viral
like uh playing with that little fear so
it's almost like a good PR because
ultimately they're not trying to put
them in the home and have a good social
connection they're trying to put them in
factories and so they they have fun with
it if you watch Boston Dynamics videos
yeah they're aware of it oh yeah they're
I mean the videos for sure that they put
out it's almost like an unspoken
tongue-in-cheek thing they they're aware
of how people are going to feel when you
have a robot that does like a flip now
most of the people are uh just like
excited about the control problem of it
like how to how to make the whole thing
happen but they're aware when people see
well I think they became aware I think
that in the beginning they were really
really focused on just the engineering I
mean they're at the Forefront of
Robotics like Locomotion and stuff
um
and then when they started doing the
videos I think that was kind of a labor
of love I know that the former CEO Mark
like he oversaw a lot of the videos and
made a lot of them himself and like he's
even really really detail-oriented like
there can't be like some sort of incline
that would give the robot an advantage
they're very like he he was very um hell
of Integrity about the authenticity of
them uh but then when they started to go
viral I think that's when they started
to realize oh there's something
interesting here that
you know I don't I don't know how much
they took it seriously in the beginning
other than realizing that they could
play Within the videos yeah I know that
they take it very seriously now what I
like about Boston Dynamics
and similar companies it's still mostly
run by engineers
but you know
I've had my criticisms there's a bit
more PR leaking in but those videos are
made by Engineers because that's what
they find fun it's like testing the
robustness of the system
I mean they uh
they're having a lot of fun there with
the robots totally
have you been have you been to visit
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's cool it's one
of the most important like I I uh
I mean because I I have
um eight uh robot dogs now uh wait you
have eight robot dogs what are they just
walking around your place like yeah I'm
working on them uh that's actually one
of my goals is
to have at any one time always a robot
moving oh I'm far away that's an
ambitious goal
well I have like more roombas that I
know what to do with the room their
program so the the programmable room was
nice and um I have a bunch of little
like I built the well I'm not finished
with the butter robot from Rick and
Morty I still have a bunch of robots
everywhere but the thing is what happens
is you're working on one robot at a time
and uh that becomes like a little
project
it's actually very difficult to have
just a passively
functioning robot always moving yeah and
that's a that's a that's a dream for me
because I'd love to create that kind of
a little world so uh the the impressive
thing about Boston Dynamics to me was to
see like hundreds of spots
and like there's a the most impressive
thing that still sticks with me is um
there was a a spot robot
walking down the hall seemingly with no
supervision whatsoever and he was
wearing he or she I don't know was
wearing a cowboy hat
it just it was just walking down the
hall and nobody paying attention and
it's just like walking down this long
Hall and I'm like looking around this is
anyone like what's happening here so I'm
presumably some kind of automation where
he's doing the map I mean the whole
environment is probably really well
mapped but I it was just
it gave me a picture of a world where a
robot is doing his thing wearing a
cowboy hat just
going down the hall like getting some
coffee or whatever like I don't know
what it's doing what's the mission but
uh I don't know for some reason that
really stuck with me you don't often see
robots that aren't part of a demo or
that aren't uh you know like with a
semi-autonomous autonomous vehicle like
directly doing a task this was just
chilling yeah walking around I don't
know well yeah you know I mean we're at
MIT like when I first got to MIT I was
like okay where's all the where's all
the robots and they were all like broken
or like not demoing so yeah and and and
what really excites me is that we're
about to have that we're about to have
so many moving rope about to well it's
coming it's coming in our lifetime that
we will just have robots moving around
we're already seeing the beginnings of
it there's delivery robots in some
cities on the sidewalks and I just love
seeing like the tick tocks of people
reacting to that because yeah you see a
robot walking down the hall with a
cowboy hat you're like what
the what is this this is awesome and
scary and kind of awesome and people
either love or hate it that's one of the
things that I think companies are
underestimating that people will either
love a robot or hate a robot and nothing
in between so it's just again an
exciting time to be alive yeah I think
kids almost universally at least in my
experience love them
a lot love legged robots if they're not
La my my son hates the room though
because ours is loud
oh that yeah no the legs the legs oh
yeah because your son
um
do they understand Roma to be a robot
oh yeah my kids
not the first words they learned they
say beep boop
does do they project intelligence out of
the thing but we don't really use it
around them anymore for the reason that
my son is scared of it
yeah that's right I think they would
like even a Roomba
because it's moving around on its own
I think kids and animals view it as a an
agent